there's a concept an advertising concept
and it's called The Purple Cow have you
ever heard of it I've heard of it what
is it so basically the Purple Cow
um concept is around standing out and
being different so essentially what he
basically said was when you're driving
along and you see a field of cows you
don't really go oh look a cow you don't
do that you see it every day it's the
same old stuff but if you drove along
one day and looked in that field and
also there was a purple cow you gotta
pull up and you're gonna go what the
hell there's a purple cow and that's the
thing about advertising and brand we're
consuming content load of content every
single day like you know even getting
here today the amount of advertising
that I see people don't realize it how
we advertising you see I think you see a
thousand in a day by the way so a
thousand adverts in a day and that could
be on billboards it could be on your
phone on Instagram so you are constantly
consuming content and the idea is that
how do we make sure we create content
that actually people see
and remember it and that's the biggest
thing